you probably remember the alleged
musical artist Lil Nas X real name
Montero Lamar Hill he came onto the
scene 5 years ago marketing himself
primarily to young children performing
at elementary schools and singing duets
with Elmo then after going out of his
way to amass this audience of minors
Hill switched course dramatically and
came out as gay and then started
releasing ridiculously vulgar and
graphically sexual songs and videos uh
only a year after dancing on stage with
the Sesame Street gang Hill put out a
music video where he performed forms a
lap dance on Satan so that kind of gives
you an idea of the pivot here there is
of course nothing especially new and
certainly nothing interesting about a
pop star who makes obscene and deviant
and stupid music but he'll set himself
apart as an especially creepy predatory
scumbag by taking the time to lure in an
audience of Elementary AE children
before making the pivot to the obscene
and deviant and stupid stuff well I
should amend that I guess because his
original single Oldtown Road was
definitely extremely stupid but it
wasn't overtly deviant or obscene he
saved that Rebrand for later and now Lil
nzx has reemerged promising a new single
that will be released on Friday titled
Jay Christ as you've already predicted
given the title Hill is uh going the
sacr route this time around as he
desperately begs for for our attention
in the leadup to his crappy song coming
out he's put out a bunch of Blasphemous
images and promos uh in one ad he's seen
crucified on a cross here's what that
looks like
you know
[Music]
I so there's that in another he is again
dressed as Jesus while scarfing down the
Eucharist and taking shots of communion
[Music]
wine and then once again again he's uh
on the cross as you could see in this
promo image uh where he's on a cross
being hoisted up uh don't worry though
as the media insists Lil nzx is not
trying to make a mockery of Jesus just
because he's mocking Jesus doesn't mean
he's trying to make a mockery of Jesus
you see people.com reports Lil nzx is
leaning back into biblical imagery for
his new era on Monday the Grammy winner
unveiled the cover artwork for his
upcoming single Jay Christ featuring
himself resembling Jesus on a cross
shortly before clarifying he's not
looking to offend any religious group
with the photo quote my new single is
dedicated to the man who had the
greatest comeback of all time wrote Lil
NS x 24 onx alongside the J Christ Comer
image and announcement the Oldtown Road
performer then quoted a previous post
claiming that his upcoming single
features a very beloved Popstar and said
it was God after reposting some fans
tweets expressing excitement for his new
music L nzx took to the social media
platform once again less than an hour
after sharing the J Christ single cover
to clarify his motive the crazy thing is
nowhere in the picture is a mockery of
Jesus he wrote Jesus's image is used
throughout history in people's art all
over the world L nzx continued I'm not
making fun of s yall just got to keep
trying to gatekeep a religion that was
here before any of us were even born
shut the f up well yes it's true Jesus
has been depicted in art for hundreds of
years but historically he was depicted
in a way meant to venerate and glorify
him there was a lot of Jesus related art
being produced in Europe in the 14th
century for example but here's the thing
if you went back in time and showed
people an image of yourself on the cross
in 14th century Europe or or you showed
yourself pounding shots of communion
wine well you're going to have to
explain that to the Inquisition and uh
it's probably not going to go well for
you and that's because this is obviously
meant to ridicule Christianity and
blaspheme Christ and that's why you know
when I say that it won't go well for you
I mean that you'll be burned at the
akake just to be
clear but Hill as usual even though he
uh you know we don't have an inquisition
these days lacks the courage to stand by
his own provocations he's a coward along
with with being a sacrilegious
degenerate and so he always does these
things with a little bit of a wink and a
nod and a little bit of a well I didn't
really mean it
offensively last year because of you
pre-born network of clinics saved over
58,000 babies thanks to you uh and
everyone who made this possible we came
down here to Jacksonville with nothing
just the clothes on our back and I knew
I had to change and it was time to
[Music]
change so I was just getting on my feet
and I met someone and I got pregnant and
I wasn't ready how am I going to raise a
baby and I barely can take care of my
daughter and myself right now I Googled
abortions and I scheduled appointment
thinking it was an abortion clinic
they did my first ultrasound seeing the
the ultrasound it impacted me to the
point to where I broke down crying the
nurse reminded me that it was a blessing
from God I was thinking about if I
wanted to keep the baby or not when I
was at the clinic after they told me how
far along I was and that the baby had a
heartbeat I cried and it gave me a
minute by myself in the room I broke
down and I prayed to God I asked the
Lord to when I walk out of those doors
to just give me the strength to be able
to go through the pregnancy made my
decision at that time Women's Center
called me out of the blue and said that
they had a lot of stuff for me and they
would like for me to come in they gave
me cribs and diapers and so much stuff
it's amazing touches my heart it makes
me feel special makes me feel like
there's people in the world that does
care they gave me hope the strength to
believe in myself that I could do it
treasure I chose because I know that she
was a gift from God and she's just going
to be a treasure I'm super grateful that
I'm able to go down this journey with my
daughter and I'm just super glad that I
didn't have abortion I've learned how to
trust God how to listen to God and to
trust myself and to do the right thing
and not be selfish it feels
[Music]
amazing when Antoinette found out she
was pregnant she was in a bad place she
didn't know uh how she could raise her
child on her own she searched for an
abortion clinic but God led her to a
pre-born clinic where she was uh
introduced to her baby via ultrasound
when she saw her baby and heard her
heartbeat she broke down crying and the
nurse reminded her that a child is a
blessing Antoinette chose life that day
pre-born saves 200 babies each and every
day for just $28 a month you can sponsor
an ultrasound and help save a life when
a mother sees her her baby on an
ultrasound and hear us his heartbeat
she's twice as likely to choose life
let's join together and help mothers
choose life just dial pound 250 and say
the keyword baby that's pound 250 or
visit preborn dcomm mat that's preborn
dcomm mat now speaking of cowardice uh
that's the first point that many people
uh make about this sort of thing the
first thing you can't help but notice is
that whenever one of these pitiful atten
I hores decides to grasp for relevance
by blaspheming a religion they always
choose the same religion you know if you
get all of your information about the
world from Hollywood films and pop music
you might come to the conclusion that
there's only one religion that exists on
the entire planet because there's only
one that attracts their mockery and
derision but as it turns out there are
many other religions including ones with
billions of adherence yet these
spineless frauds who want to be seen as
bold and transgressive are very careful
to only transgress the one world
religion that you can get away with
transgressing the one you're allowed to
disrespect while still being celebrated
in the mainstream and accepted by our
cultural Elites and everything else you
know
there's one religious group that you are
allowed to offend without suffering any
consequence whatsoever and these Brave
and daring artists are very careful to
stay safely inside that particular
box why is that well first because
people like Hill are again fraudulent
cowards they want to build a
transgressive brand without doing or
saying anything that actually is
transgressive in our culture you know
I'm not sure there's much value in being
shocking and offensive just for the sake
of being shocking and offensive but I
know for sure that there's absolutely
zero value in pretending to being
shocking and offensive while studiously
avoiding doing anything that our society
actually deems shocking and offensive
you know it's one thing to be a shock
jock it's another thing to be a neutered
balless little puppy pretending to be a
shock jock and that's the category that
Lil nzx falls
into
but I must admit uh we as Christians are
not blameless here the other reason that
Christianity is the only mockable
religion is that we have allowed it to
be the only MO able religion you know
Hill will dress up like Jesus and
pretend to be crucified making a parody
out of our most sacred image but we all
know that he would never in a million
years even consider dressing up like
Muhammad for example and why is that
well that's because Muslims simply will
not tolerate that sort of disrespect
they just won't tolerate it and that's
why it doesn't happen and there was a
time uh many centuries ago when
Christians wouldn't tolerate it either
but then Christianity in the west became
infected with the disease of liberalism
and most of our leaders started
preaching that tolerance is our greatest
virtue never mind the fact that Jesus
Christ himself never once called us to
be tolerant never talked about it and in
fact demonstrated forceful even violent
intolerance when he drove the money
changers out of the temple with a whip
but that story like so many others in
both the old New Testament isn't
mentioned very often by our priests and
pastors instead they preach about some
new modern totally invented version of
Jesus who from the way they tell it
would likely be a corporate Dei
administrator if he was walking the
Earth
today we have become a weak and impotent
church that tolerates ridicule and so
that's exactly what we
get but whatever the reason for this
Dynamic the fact is that there is
nothing provocative or new or bold or
interesting in about somebody making fun
of Christianity or engaging in
anti-christian sacrilege pop stars have
been doing that for 40 years Marilyn
Manson was portraying himself as
crucified back in the 90s modern artists
were submerging crucifixes in tanks of
urine in the
80s you're not being subversive with
this stuff you're just jumping on a
bandwagon that's been chugging along for
decades now it may be Blasphemous and
objectionable but it's also played out
and
boring and that's where we're left in
our culture of
these people have been trying to shock
us with the same tired routine since the
Reagan
Administration and a guy like little
nasx uh he he has no musical ability to
speak of no Artistic integrity no skill
or Talent of any kind and so he relies
on empty provocation but even his
provocations are trite and
derivative we're not shocked anymore by
the profane and the vulgar because we've
seen it a million times where we are
swimming in this sewage every day of Our
Lives
he's just adding another
bucket and no one even notices
anymore and that is why Lil nzx is again
today cancelled thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts